có hỏi đặc gian có phạc ấy là trong cái điều trị hí mù chỉ có dễ nhất là điều trị hủ tình trong yên phía không
phạc lại mắt cuộc các trị gọi trọng mà tình tin thúc nghỉ, in phải đến phải được từ vấn ở điều trị hí không
hợp ra thì người nhương khi mù cũng rất là nhiều những thương hợp nào có chỉ đến dịch bạng phải là tình thúc nghỉ
còn những trường hợp nào chứa có chỉ đến từ tin thúc nghỉ và chúng ta có thể sẽ trị trụ những việc phát
rất dạng hơn, sĩ nhàng hơn, mặt có thay đường thì chúng ta vẫn nên tính hành,
ở tụi nó biết dụ như là một trường hợp mà cũng ở với dụ như ta chỉ có một lý trọng một lần rồi,
không tụng trọng, không tất cả những kịch, bương nhân thì cũng có khác cho khi thăm khám đều vấn thường hợp,
khi bạn thì thì mình làm cái dễ pháp cho chúng đậu đi ở giọc tình trong nơi, thì như bạn thì giải quyết được những người nhìn sắp,
và là vì sao mà người của lưới khó, có thay và khi mà chúng ta dạy biết được rồi thì thì là chúng ta có lưới người của người,
chúng ta có giao mà cần chưa cần phải bước vào trong thúc xin trống nhìn,
ở vì vậy thì thúc xin trống nhìn nó là một tính, tại vì chúng ta có hiểu hãn,
nhưng mà không như thế, có tạch đất trường hợp chúng ta đều có thể là mà chúng xin trống nhìn,
ở vì tôi cũng chân nằm xem với các cấp dân nhìn trường hợp,
chỉ cần có thể thăm trả mà mình có thể là mình thác tập nhìn hợp,
là phải thật trăm là có tình dụng người gà nó,
cho nên trong điều để hấp dẫn,
nếu là chúng ta có thể là đa dẹp, có thể nhìn sống cáp dịch của nở màn thái,
hình thành đồng ý những chuyện hẳng là chỉ đánh thì chúng ta cũng có thể cần nhắc xem
bờ đặc ứng được ý như cầu của những khi chúng không cần tụng chỉ phía quá cao,
bờ là cái thời gian nhé nó sẽ trạch những cái trạch màn thái.